well I have been known to get up and
dance when there's music and this right
here is exactly why Keith Urban and
Nicole Kidman are the epitome of
relationship goals I'm already ready for
this pitbull collaboration thank you and
carries on the record to care and of its
own there as well wait what was there
and of its own there as well turns out
the Idol judge has joined forces with
the Idol winner for collaboration on his
new album rip Court and that news it
went right over my head lot of country
music stars expects to hear pitbull on
an album I think it's a the song we
wrote is called Sun don't let me down
just needing a few more hours of night
to seal the deal so don't come up son
stay right where you are that's the gist
of the song who better than the sexy
swagger a pitbull to seal the deal yeah
who's pillar on it I can't wait to hear
no doubt Nicole was also dancing along
in the audience at the ACM Awards on
Sunday where Keith performed his brand
new single
you